tout de suite notre panel politique on y
va josée legault
chantal hébert michel david bonsoir
bonsoir soit on va parler d'eux des
cibles canadiennes mais d'abord on va
parler de la nouvelle de la journée et
de ce qui vient d'être annoncé à ottawa
donc fermeture des frontières suspension
de tous les vols venant de l'inde et du
pakistan tour de table là dessus josée
legault n'a pas pris de temps là non il
ya quand même une leçon qui a été
apprise parce que avec le début de la
pandémie on se souvient l'an dernier a
été un cauchemar tout le tac le premier
ministre canadien offre prix à agir sur
les frontières sans parler des passoires
qui était devenu si nos aéroports donc
dans le village y est de toute évidence
les premiers ministres des provinces lui
ion lui ont parlé sur le sujet de
manière assez appuyée j'entendais bien
ce que vous avez l'impression que même
au risque d'aller trop vite même si on
n'a pas toutes les données scientifiques
sur le fameux varia et son influence
on s'est dit on prend leur peau de
chagrin politiquement le prix trop fort
que d'attendre une journée deux ou trois
jours ça se joue en grande partie en
ontario parce que la majorité de ces
voix-là attaqué cette personne au
l'ancien chef du parti conservateur
celui qui a précédé monsieur ford qui
est maintenant premier ministre patrick
brown et maires de la région qui inclut
les niveaux par personne et lui
demandait mais qu au comble c'est beau
l'aï demandé confirme l'aéroport alors
ça me donne une idée de l'humeur en
interview
d'autre part lorsque j'ai trouvé
intéressant c'est josé aux raisons on a
eu parce que en lisant les informations
qui sortent le tout on ne fait pas cette
fois ci que dire les vols en provenance
de l'inde
on dit aussi les voyageurs qui sont
parties de l'inde pour transiter par à
un autre endroit pour revenir au canada
devront à cet autre endroit passer un
test et présenter un test négatif
en clair parce que c'est vous connaissez
voyage et je sais que vous les
connaissez pas très difficile
trouver un vol délit quelque part
quelque part toronto et est donc on a
aussi fermé cette porte là il ya un an
il y aurait probablement celle david oui
enfin la bonne entre nous agi plus
rapidement que question d'habitude
maintenant ça ça pose quand même le
problème des canadiens qui sont à
l'extérieur c'est très bien l'oeil à la
peau de tourisme de masse le au cours
des prochains mois prochaine peut-être
deux prochaines années mais il ya des
ressortissants canadiens qui vont
vouloir revenir avec raison au pays
et c'est vrai qu'on y est facile de
trouver une autre voie que le vol direct
et c'est à ce moment là là je suis un
petit peu plus dubitatif sur les
contrôles qui vont être effectués dans
les aéroports ont cessé il ya toutes
sortes de façons d'éviter soit le test
dans les fautes est et plusieurs médias
ont fait la démonstration que c'est
facile d'en obtenir est la quarantaine à
l'hôtel on voit qu'il ya des parts de
services qui permettent d'échapper alors
c'est très bien il faut applaudir la
rapidité avec laquelle le gouvernement
trudeau a agi mais il faut s'assurer que
les souris passeront pas par d'autres
personnes je demande enregistrée pas
prévu mais comme on a eu des avec la
conférence de presse si on avait
l'extrait de fort qu'on devait passer en
début parce que quand chantal dit faut
mesurer l'état d'esprit en ontario je
disais les chefs du québec se stabilise
depuis plusieurs jours
et c'est pas le cas en ontario et c'est
loin d'être le cas en fait en ontario
donc quand j'aurai ford quand vous
voulez mais bon on va écouter pour mieux
faire un point de presse ce matin
je vais attendre ça puis je veux avoir
votre avis
oui mesdames take that i'm sorry
chatel je commence avec vous et comment
vous lisez l'actuel ce fait une semaine
qu'on n'avait pas vu à peu près comment
vous analyser ce qui se passe en interne
au leadership de monsieur x de lien de
confiance entre les gouvernements les
premiers ministres provinciaux le
premier fédéral et la population est un
élastique mais on est là c'est que
fragiliser dans que de l'ontario semaine
dernière j'ai quoi bois brûlé les
journées la fonction publique n'est pas
j'ai jamais vu un ressac comme celui de
la fin de semaine dernière la conférence
de presse d'aujourd'hui aurinienne
arrangé pour vous donner un exemple
le maire de toronto le maire de thil
c'est comme si la mer est ce le temps de
décider eux qui vont fermer des
entreprises quand il n'y a plus que 5
codes qu'ovide et attendre plus appeler
québec
je vous dis que le problème de monsieur
fortier qui a perdu et le point de
presse d'aujourd'hui voit pas vraiment
regrettable parce que les larmes aux
yeux il avait peu de nouvelles mesure où
peu de preuves à fournir qu'il avait eu
plus de situations
puis les mesure qu'avait annoncée du
m'excuse tapas est bonne sa lettre
aurait donc on le savait
effectivement josée leroux c'est rare
qu'on voit cet état de désarroi
j'ai un premier ministre c'est le bon
bout il avait l'air vraiment perdu et
dont les émotions on peut on peut
comprendre mais on voit vraiment un
premier ministre qui est presque en
panique et qui ne semble plus avoir le
contrôle de la situation alors chante
elle a non seulement eu raison sur
l'autorité morale qui est perdu mais
vraiment vraiment on le sent aux
antipodes de françois legault finalement
waimes jade avait devancé de shell comme
l'école nous sommes à cesta mais quoi qu
on a connu des semaines guy moussi la
relation et ne pas voir monsieur le
groupe annonce un jour on n'avait jamais
vu ça
non et on n'a jamais vu monsieur legault
s'effondrer comme ça non plus j'imagine
les gens qui regardent ce qui se disent
qu est-ce que ce gars là est encore
capable de faire la job ou au cours des
prochains mois parce que le monsieur
monsieur faure dans l'air vraiment de de
s'effondrer littéralement et je peux le
comprendre mais ont ils pu imaginer au
québec la la police qui dit non le
gouvernement nous dit de faire telle
chose on le fera pas c'est moi j'ai
jamais vu ça c'est tout à fait sérieuses
et pas simplement la population mais les
instruments anormaux de gouvernement
refuse de fonctionner alors je comprends
le désarroi de monsieur fort et on
devrait vraiment s'inquiéter on devrait
juste rapide on devrait s'inquiéter de
ce qui se passe là bas parce que c'est
juste à côté est et on est vraiment
prend beaucoup d'empathie pour ce
qu'elle est les ontariens vivent en ce
moment comme vous disiez nous les
québécois on a vécu assez graves des
choses très graves l'an dernier mais
c'est vraiment ma chère qui stoppe la
balle et sur le plan de la pandémie et
sur le plan politique il ya des gens qui
vont vous dire néanmoins que peut-être
que c'est une bonne nouvelle que
monsieur ford soit en désarroi pense que
ça va permettre à des adultes eux
reprendre le contrôle de la situation
alors que dans la première et deuxième
vingt
il avait ça a été une occasion pour lui
de se transformer enfin aux yeux de
plusieurs personnes
ok climat tour de table rapide je serai
absolument vous parlez de du de dix
attaques de monsieur legault que le
mandat mangane sur l'histoire du la loi
21 mai tour de table je croisais vous
monsieur david sur le climat je vous ai
entendu le retrouver monsieur guilbeault
bon on a monté les cibles au canada lui
dit croyez moi vous allez voir l'an
prochain ça va vraiment commencer à
baisser alors on verra mais qu'est ce
que vous en dites
ben moi j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour
monsieur guilbeault mais je constate que
l'écologiste qu'il était devenu un
policier et quand on l'attend commenter
les déclarations du directeur
parlementaire du budget il lui dit non
non monsieur
son nom m'échappe les acteurs
parlementaire repos dit qu' il faudrait
avoir à 250 dollars la tonne pour une
case au cap où il dit qu'à partir de 100
$ ça commencerait est efficace mais on
recommence et efficace pour atteindre la
cible il ya toute une marge et je peux
pas m'empêcher de constater que il ya
lundi sera pas si longtemps la madame
fuilet nous annonçaient 36 % de baisse
d'émissions et que quatre jours plus
tard on est presque rendu à 45
waouh il s'est passé quelque chose dans
ce but c'est pour être sérieux et
d'autre part je peux pas m'empêcher non
plus de voir la coïncidence entre le
chiffre de 17,6 milliards que mme adam
freeland a annoncé pour l'économie verte
et les 18 milliards que le gouvernement
fédéral a quand même investi dans
l'industrie pétrolière l'an dernier
alors
c'est bien travaillé sur la source sur
les plus mais il faudrait commencer à
travailler sur les - chantal on pourrait
discuter de 6 steven guilbeault
écologiste était pas déjà un politicien
mais bon on va lier deux choses d'abord
il faudrait pas laisser le spectacle
d'aujourd'hui complètement éclipser le
fait qu'on a assisté à un changement de
paradigme qui je fais un important pour
le canada c'est à dire que c'est le plus
grand changement entre 30 et bayonne ce
changement de paradigme sur les
changements climatiques
après avoir passé des années à avoir un
partenaire américain qui voulait rien
faire et qui s'y intéressait pas le
canada se fait pousser dans le dos et on
ne sait quand les états unis pour le
canada l'inde ou le canada a intérêt à
avancer
donc ça fait une immense différence pour
les cibles vont 36% et presque 45 points
36% et presque 40
la vérité c'est que dans le moment dans
les intentions de vote et d'évolution
très bien le choix semble être entre le
gouvernement de monsieur autour qui
restait à 30% qui en ferait encore moins
celui de monsieur trudeau qui dit au
moins on a l'ambition d'en faire plus je
suis convaincu que ça faisait partie du
calcul une josette mais oui c'est c'est
un positionnement aussi pré électorale
c'est sûr que face au parti conservateur
dont une majorité de militants ont même
refusé de reconnaître l'existence des
changements climatiques c'est un outil
c'est une arme de plus entre les mains
de justin trudeau
mais là maintenant grâce à l'effet au
président américain comme un mouvement
qui s'est prime
maintenant c'est toujours la même
question est ce que les résultats se
retrouvent rendez vous bien et secourir
exactement alors je vous fais en temps
je vous disais que je veux parler de de
cet échange qu'a eu lieu cette
déclaration de monsieur legault
aujourd'hui sur tous les candidats
depuis ce qu'elles avaient échoué aux
tests
compte tenu de sa position sur la loi 21
la clause nonobstant on écoute les deux
on revient je pense que dominique
anglade vient d'échouer son test de
leadership est incapable de défendre les
valeurs des québécois ont aussi une
grande majorité des québécois qui sont
d'accord avec la loi 21
il ya une grande majorité de québécois
qui disent les personnes en autorité
devrait pas porter de signes religieux
on sait maintenant que le jugement que
pour y arriver on a besoin de la clause
dérogatoire
puis madame anglade laisse tomber les
québécois a pas de son caucus
on sait que la clause dérogatoire est
renouvelable tous les cinq ans donc ça
sera dans le prochain mandat du prochain
gouvernement
donc madame anglade viennent nous
annoncer que si jamais il y avait un
gouvernement libéral d'un repos appuyer
la majorité des québécois vos potes
défendre les valeurs québécoises
je ne renierai pas la clause nonobstant
cela dit je suis pour la laïcité mais je
ne renouvellerai pas la cause 1 900
c'est la position que nous avons
présentement la loi sur la laïcité j'ai
toujours dit qu'elle devrait passer le
test des tribunaux qu'on ne renouvelait
pas la clause nonobstant et c'est la
position du parti libéral
alors michel invite qu'est ce que vous
avez lu dans ses commentaires de
monsieur legault aujourd'hui monsieur
legault beau jeu madame madame gilad est
complètement coincé et elle était
d'entrée de jeu dès le début dès le
début du débat le dit moi je ne
renouvellerai pas la clause dérogatoire
alors madame anglade dit je suis pour la
laïcité mais il est certain que si elle
enlève la clause nonobstant la loi un
certain on verra ce que la cour suprême
décidera mais disons 14 période nous
donne une indication la loi vont être
déclarées inopérantes alors il y en a
aux portes du tout si madame langlade
était conséquente avec elle-même à dire
eh ben moi je choisi d'abolir la loi
c'est mon choix les québécois m'ont élu
là on pourrait dire le québec choisit
mais en décidant simplement de laisser
ça allait aux tribunaux elle renonce
finalement au doigt de du québec de
choisir ce qu'il veut comme règle en
matière de laïcité
et oui elle va devoir je pense comment
dire
charrier 7 pour tradiction là pendant
toute la campagne électorale je fais une
précision pour ceux qui se demanderaient
oui mais pourquoi parce qu'à chaque 5
quand un gouvernement utilise la clause
dérogatoire ça doit être renouvelée
c'est pas une police d'assurance vie
c'était pour forcer 1re débat canton
canton donc on se met à l'abri de loi
qui pourrait être par ailleurs jugé
discriminatoire bon chantal hébert je
suis d'accord avec michel david
la position du parti libéral du québec
qui était possiblement défendable avant
le jugement la cour va le devenir de
moins en moins c'est assez clair pas
besoin d'être un grand juriste pour les
rentes et link 6 ab polluent la clause
dérogatoire la loi 21 avait été jugée
contraire à la charte des lois des
droits et donc inconstitutionnelle et ce
serait étonnant que plus tard on peut
pas présumer que la cour suprême la cour
d'appel en arrive à des situations
différentes
donc madame en gardant une position sur
la clôture sur une clôture qui s'est
plus ou moins écroulé j'ai eu aussi un
grand malaise quand n'importe quel chef
politique décide de quelles sont les
valeurs de tout le monde et mais qu'est
ce qu'une omerta sur quelqu'un qui
défend un autre point de vue il ya quand
même un nombre important de québécois
qui voit pas la loi 21 comme étant la
voie vers la laïcité est ce que ça fait
d'eux des mauvais québécois ça me
rappelle un peu le cas les libéraux
fédéraux disait que tout le monde qui
était pas d'accord avec lui étaient des
séparatistes je n'étais pas à l'aise
dans ce camp ne suis pas plus à l'aise
quand monsieur legault se pose en juge
ce qui l'a le défenseur des valeurs
québécoises
mais c'est pour ça dit vous puis michel
ou si vous dites quand même anglade
prennent l'autre cas en disant ma
laïcité mois ne passe pas par une
interdiction des signes religieux points
ou peut-être uniquement aux testera pour
les gens notorité coercitive mais pas
pour le raid donc mais effectivement
hockey joseph j'en ai tout oui même si
c'est elle c'est un glissement des
discours politiques aujourd'hui qui a
commencé sous le parti québécois et
pauline marois avec la charte des
valeurs alors les bons québécois était
pour la charte des valeurs puis d autres
profité des mauvais match qu'ils
semblaient pas comprendre et ça c'est de
me rit et c'est un effet déplorable
sur le plan politique je dirais que
monsieur legault et a été vraiment un
bon joueur d'échecs strictement son plan
politique la clause dérogatoire
l'utiliser je pense pour deux raisons
premièrement parce qu'il devait être
drôlement ce but est que elle allait
déclarer justement inconstitutionnelle
devant les tribunaux à sa face même mais
deuxièmement parce que ce faisant ils
posaient une bombe politique à
retardement sous le parti libéral du
québec parce que justement à cause de
ceux de ce délai de ces cas où après 5 à
elle pour soit renouvelé la clause
dérogatoire ou ne pas la renouveler
évidemment ça pied j'ai complètement le
parti libéral et madame anglade se
retrouve aujourd'hui on est fait piéger
et là elle et elle est incapable par
créer justement de perdre le peu d'appui
qu'elle est chez les francophones de
dire clairement toujours moi je suis
opposé à l'interdiction des signes
religieux mais mon parti est opposé à
l'interdiction des signes religieux pour
les personnes en position d'autorité et
demi non je suis pro mais je ne
renouvelle pas la clause dérogatoire ce
qui veut dire je vais jeter la loi 21 en
pâture littéralement aux tribunaux alors
sa position propre position est vraiment
elle est intenable mais elle devra vivre
avec mais je peux me permettre d'aller
me chercher parce que certains disaient
la question n'est pas tant de savoir à
ce que la loi 21 est bonne nous est pas
bon c'est de savoir est ce que on a le
droit d'adopter la loi qu'on veut doit
faire des choix des mauvais choix selon
certains mais mais c'est notre choix et
de ne pas se le faire dicter par des
juges non élus
c'est un vieux débat qui équipe au
québec
mais ultimement c'est ça la question est
ce qu'on peut décider nous ce qu'on va
faire ou on n'a pas ce droit là leur vin
mais c'est sa com prend avec le québec
ne peut pas il le québec qui soumis
comme les autres provinces à l'ordre
constitutionnel
cannes est oui mais même ok je suis
joueur lance jean manglobe en habitat
merci beaucoup au franc parler mon moi
on a fait un bon tour de table là dessus
merci à vous trois doigts pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit